Daniel Friedman: All right.
Greetings, everyone.
It's June 20, 2023.
We're in our second discussion on chapter
six.
So we'll first just have any general
comments or anything.
Then we'll turn to the questions table
and look at what questions we didn't get
to last time and just kind of revisit,
maybe condense some questions or just see
what we can do with what is here.
So anyone just want to make any general
comments on chapter six?
Andrew Pashea: I believe this is the second
session on chapter six, right?
Daniel: Correct.
Andrew: Or maybe I lost.
Daniel: Okay.
Yeah, it is.
Yeah.
There was only one onboarding needed for
the welcome back here, so we started one
week faster into the rhythm.
Okay.
So it looks like these were the questions
I remember we left off with this one.
Let's just develop this into what was
into a question, and then we'll continue
on.
Okay.
Is there a common or good representation
or rubric for evaluating Generative Model
Generative process, which is change it to
Generative Models and Generative
Processes?
Anyone want to give a first thought or
just some other related question?
Andrew: Go on, please.
Sorry.
Daniel: No, it's okay.
Andrew: Yeah, I'm not sure about what's
the exact criteria for evaluating
generative models or generative processes,
, but one thing is for sure that, well, I
mean, one of the main at least when
evaluating generative model one of our
main.
Criteria should be how closely it tracks
our situation of interest and
specifically how relevant it is for
addressing the question we're trying to
examine.
I don't think it's something clear cut or,
, I don't know, written in stone.
And based on the context and the
situation, the Evaluation Criteria rubric
should be different, I suppose, both for
generative Model and generative process.
Daniel: Yeah.
So again, we'll revisit this Generative
Model Generative process question later,
following the recent Livestream, but
generative process working with
generative process as the underlying
process that gives rise to the
observations.
This would seem to be more adequate to
the extent that it can better describe
the measurements.
Generative Model, similarly, is being
evaluated based upon its ability to fit
to the generative process as well as
phenomena of interest.
So not just to fit visual data, but maybe
to model something like some illusion in
visual, then there's a wide range of more
general statistical modeling techniques.
So first is like the ultimate grab bag,
which is just how relevant is the overall
modeling.
Then there are statistical evaluations of
model adequacy and model selection.
Ike information criterion.
Bayesian information criterion, base
factor.
Hierarchical likelihood ratio test.
If you have a parametric Model Bootstrap
and non parametric statistics.
Just general modeling, and then taking
that more out of the statistics into the
Engineering Model Lifecycle, then that's
where you can think about validation,
verification, validity, quality, et
cetera.
Systems engineering model lifecycle.
Any other thoughts or questions on this?
Okay.
Speaker C: I'm coming from kind of an
early career data scientist background
here, but as far as what I find
attractive about active inference and
doing things as generative models is the
attempt to describe or explain what's
going on in the data.
And that being said, in terms of a lot of
many applications of data science and
machine learning, the emphasis is upon
prediction.
And so are these listed statistical
metrics you have here base factor, BIC,
et cetera?
Are those basically like your error
measurements?
Are they your, how to say, just attempt
at measuring like accuracy of prediction
or or is there some trade off between
explainability and prediction, if that
makes sense?
Daniel: Yeah, just to kind of summarize
these.
So when you have nested parametric models,
, then you can evaluate whether two
models are better in terms of including
or not some parametric factor and then
testing for their likelihood ratios.
So this is a pretty straightforward test,
but it's pretty limited to just strictly
nested parametric models.
So just getting that out of the way.
In general, we're in the Bayesian setting.
.
And so one of the advantages of the
Bayesian setting is that you can compare
two different models that have totally
different architectures on the same data
set.
So one way that that's done is with this
Ike information criterion or the Bayesian
information criterion.
Both of them do something very similar,
which is they reward model fit and they
penalize the number of parameters.
So actually in that way it's a lot like
equation 2.5.
You want to reward the fit but penalize
the complexity of the model.
Base factor is kind of like the Hlrt, but
it doesn't have to be ratios of nested
models.
You can just compare the relative
evidence in favor of one model or another.
.
So this is used in structure modeling and
structure learning, but this is all kind
of like testing amongst a portfolio of
models, which ones are better?
Then how do you really get into the space
of like, well, how effective is this
model?
You could test on a new data set, you
could do all the regular techniques like
cross validation, leave one out, et
cetera, or test on a new data set.
But then the very interesting question is
how do you establish the efficacy of an
action model?
Because it's not just a passive inference
model.
So there you would need to get into like
benchmarks like the OpenAI gym and other
other settings where you can actually
test the efficacy of an action model
against some test input, rather than just
a recognition model in some input.
But that gets so situational that there's
not like general there's not as many
general considerations there.
Another strategy is actually to even if
it seems like a passive inference problem,
, like the MNIST digit data set, you
could frame that in terms of the labeling
is an action.
So sometimes you can then take what seems
to be a passive inference problem and
then frame it as an active inference
problem.
So then you don't need to worry about
these kind of like out of sample novel
context action models, you can just kind
of use standard benchmarks.
Andrew: Also, as far as I know, probably
the only serious work on benchmarking the
performance of active inference models is
the work of Theofi Champion and his
colleagues branching time active
inference, which is they have proposed
several different variants of branching
time active inference, each of which with
increasing performance in terms of their
benchmarks.
And aside from that, I'm not aware of any
other work that takes this benchmarking
study seriously enough to be reliable.
Daniel: I guess, yeah, surely there's a
lot of proprietary work in this area.
The paper discussed in live stream eight
scaling active inference.
So here they used like the kind of
several standard testing environments I
forget the pendulum, the hopper, and then
I think like the mountain car or maybe
that's not this one, but they test the
standard AI tests.
All right, just looking just going
through the ones.
All right.
Are the transitions be independent from
the emissions?
So for context, we're talking about
Figure 7.3, discrete time active
inference.
Are the transitions independent from the
emissions?
And what does the next observation depend
on?
Short answer yes, they're independent.
That's the sparsity of the Bayes graph.
So we can clarify and give it a cleaner
textual answer.
But yes, the conditional independencies,
which is the sparsity of the base graph
which allows us to do factorized
variational inference and get all of
these advantages.
That's exactly what we're looking at.
So this visual graphical model is the
sparsity architecture of the conditional
independencies.
So yes, A and B are conditionally
independent.
Conditionally independent based on what?
Hidden state.
That's how Markov blanket works.
Conditionally dependent on the blanket.
A and B are independent.
That's true of all Bayesian graphs.
So without worrying about the Markov
blanket and the interface and the
cybernetic agent and all of that, just
any node that intervenes between two
other nodes is the Markov blanket in that
setting.
And then some other node, something else
is blanketing it from something else.
But yes, they're conditionally
independent.
What does the next observation depend
on?
Well, a matrix is the emission matrix
tail of two densities.
It can emit from a hidden state or it can
recognize from an observation.
So any given observation is only
dependent upon the hidden state at that
time and the hidden state at the next
time is only dependent upon the
transition matrix.
The transition matrix has a slice for
every action that can be taken.
Every policy makes a slice in the B
tensor.
So it's like temperature in the room,
hidden state, thermometer observation
turn on the heater or not?
And there's some B matrix for the heater
is on.
is not on.
Those are two slices in the same object.
And then policy selection means which
submatrix of B, which slice of B?
Should we multiply this to get to the
next time step.
And then what observation would I expect
there?
Good kind of standard question.
Okay, what is the relevance of thinking
about good regulator theorem for thinking
about the generative model?
So, from Cybernetics, good regulator
theorem originally stated every good
regulator of a system must be a model of
that system.
Or more accurately, every good regulator
must contain a model of that system.
Here's a few quotes from the textbook.
One way to approach this.
Again, these are all kind of vague
questions, but we can just see them many
times.
What happens to bad regulators?
Well, information processing, sense
making, decision making has a non zero
informational cost land hour limit.
There's a certain amount of actual jewels
it takes to write and erase a bit.
It from bit Chris Fields, everything that
is in that area.
So information processing is never free.
So in a dissipative and even adversarial
universe, to fail to regulate is to fail
to exist.
How do we operationalize regulation in
this setting?
That's going to be revisiting some non
equilibrium steady state.
So if we're an observer looking at a
system, in order for us to measure it as
signal relative to noise, it has to be
persistently remeasurable over the
background.
So we have to repeatedly measure it or an
organism, let's just say, can remeasure
itself.
So minimizing surprise about its
homeostatic temperature is being adaptive.
.
Now, if temperature were just flat and so
you could be unsurprised at homeostasis
by doing nothing, you'd get lazy agents.
But if temperature was really variable
and contextual and there was kind of
these nonlinear cues in the environment
and all of that, then in order to reduce
surprise about temperature, you'd end up
coming to effectively have a model of the
causal nexus that gives rise to
observations.
So the structure of the generative model
doesn't have to be the structure of the
generative process.
However, they may come to have certain
isomorphisms with each other or at least
statistical regularities.
If there's actually a 24 hours cycle in
temperature, then you're going to see
some kind of oscillatory model in the
generative model.
So there's more to say there.
But this is one good note.
Perhaps rather than good or bad regulator,
, the language of morality or preference,
the language should be accurate and
inaccurate, effective, ineffective,
viable inviable skillful, unskillful.
So there's always many ways to see it.
But basically, if the generative model in
the limit case, it just totally knows the
causal architecture of the world, that's
the easiest way to be absolutely
unsurprised and to have things as you
expect prefer is literally know how they'
're going to play out.
That's not plausible.
We use course grading and approximations
and heuristics like variational inference.
.
So the best we can do is just iteratively
optimize towards bounding surprisal.
So it's kind of like an empirical
optimizable heuristic for being a good
regulator without getting too bogged down
into the philosophy and the exactitude
the point is the ones that do well enough
to live, live ones that don't do well
enough, don't.
But active inference is in the lineage of
cybernetics.
So it's unsurprising that good.
Regulator theorem requisite diversity.
Viable systems models.
A lot of things in the Cybernetics
ontology have a natural home.
In the active ontology, they're talking
about the same territory adaptive agents.
.
So it's not surprising that they don't
invalidate each other or anything like
that.
Andrew: And actually, I think it's one of
the reasons cybernetics has experienced
kind of revitalization in recent years,
especially in the past couple of years.
Daniel: All right, how can organs other
than the brain be making inferences?
So there's a few angles on this.
The first angle or Ali or anyone else
want to give a thought?
Andrew: One thing to point is this sense
of kind of semi PANC computationalism
that if not pan computationalism, but
something that bestows inference not only
to complex self organizing systems such
as the brain, but even to very simple
linear systems, even a system as simple
as an inert rock.
So basically, it covers a spectrum from
the point of view of FEP.
There isn't anything specifically unique
about the brain.
In other words, the same mathematical
technology can be applied both to inert
rocks as well as the brain.
So in my opinion, this question should be
turned on its head.
And it's not that how does inference can
be seen in other systems, other simpler
systems, but rather, the relevant
question should be how does active
inference or the notion of inference,
inactive inference literature applies to
all of those situations.
So one way to do that is to define a kind
of sparse coupling between the
environment and the agent and define
variational density as the internal
states of the system.
And also, obviously, the external states
of the environment would be the states
that needs to be tracked by those
variational densities.
And in this case, there isn't anything
inherently different between the way the
brains or, I don't know, even sentient
agents somehow undertake inference from
the way that the inert rocks can
partition their states into internal and
external states.
But the main difference would be the way
the Markov blanket in those simpler
systems can act as a kind of statistical
boundary that allows for non causal
relationships I'm sorry, nonlinear causal
relationships as opposed to linear causal
relationships as opposed to nonlinear
causal relationships as observed in
complex agents or systems.
That's some of the main distinctions
between those.
Daniel: Awesome.
Yeah.
And then the classic paper that we often
return to, like Ollie mentioned, the
inert rock.
So this paper has the kind of visual
taxonomy from simpler to more
sophisticated agents that's by sometimes
the papers are in white, sometimes they'
're in black.
Here inert systems, active, classical
conservative systems, strange systems
with world models of their own and all of
this.
But this is a great response, which is in
a pan computationalist or pan cognitive
pan inferentialist world, then how does
active inference apply?
One other angle is like, let's just think
about the liver or the pancreas and blood
sugar.
That's our system of interest.
Realism is like, is the pancreas actually
doing inference on blood sugar?
And people can have a range of opinions,
but in a pan cognitiveist world, the
answer is yes.
Or one can kind of pull back and just say,
, we're going to model the pancreas as
doing inference on blood sugar.
So it is no different.
It's just an interpretation of the same
statistical apparatus, basically.
But there might be a setting where
scientific realism is more justified.
There's multiple lines of converging
evidence.
The model is comprehensive and being used
to generate unique explanations and
predictions versus, like, we're just
going to do a linear relationship between
these two things in the public health.
And so then we're not going to confuse
the linear model with those with the
actual causal architecture.
But there are situations that you can
design or analyze where the sparsity
structure of the system, which as early
points to is what grants it all these
interesting properties.
It is becoming known to an extent that
within two or three or four sigma, it's
like we're starting to talk about how it
is not mistaking the map for the
territory, that's the map territory
fallacy, but also not doing some kind of
map denialism, which is the map territory
fallacy, fallacy.
And that's the paper which I'll add into
by Maxwell et al.
Andrew: And also, if I may add another
point with regard to the distinction
between realism and instrumentalism.
I believe, at least in the realism school,
, probably the most relevant or well
situated stance to reframe active
inference.
I mean, reframe its ontological status is
structural realism, as argued by Majid.
Benny and others in several papers.
Daniel: Nice.
Yes.
He's joined several discussions and it's
great to okay, so there's some quotes
from the book, but yes, basically, forget
organs other than the brain, how could
anything be doing inference?
And then another angle to take is just
like the way that a baseball computes a
parabola.
You don't need to think that it's doing
it like a calculator, but that's kind of
like naturalizing the computation.
That's a path of least action in a
spatial space.
But also you could have a path of least
action in a cognitive space.
That's Bayesian Mechanics.
And then you could have more of a realist
or more of an instrumentalist angle.
Yeah, please.
Andrew: Sorry.
Just one thing that somehow I mean, gets
confused is some sometimes people think
FEP's claim is that, okay, so if a self
organizing if FEP formalism applies to a
self organizing system, then it should
persist through time by preserving its
markup blankets intact.
But actually the claim of the FEP is the
other way around.
So its main assertion is that if anything
persists through time, how does FEP
applies to it?
So in other sense, FEP doesn't provide
any justification per se for describing
the way that the system persists through
time.
But we take the persistence of the system
through time as the premise and then
apply FEP to somehow investigate the
implications of that premise through
Bayesian mechanics and FEP formalism.
Daniel: Yeah, without the implicit or
explicit acknowledgment of the persistent
existence of what you're measuring or
yourself, you don't even have something
to discuss.
And a lot of times when people just start
to specify what they mean by the nouns
and the verbs and the adjectives they use,
, that's a deflationary approach.
What if there's something that comes into
being so fast in between moments and it's
not being measured and you can't detect
it?
It's like, well, then how do you know it'
's there?
That's not within that statistical
sensing apparatus.
So you have to take the existence of the
thing to be primary in modeling some
thing.
And Axle Constant has a lot of work in
that area.
Andrew: Daniel, could you please pull up
the path integral paper on page four, if
I may?
Sorry.
Daniel: Yep, here we nice.
Andrew: Thank you.
Exactly right there.
The FTP addresses the following question.
.
Daniel: And it's like, well, if we're
talking about something that exists even
in a mental geometry, that's what we want.
.
We want to start with if it exists, even
hypothetically.
So people say, can it really describe all
things?
It's like, well, all the things that
exist or could exist.
We could use this modeling approach to
model and talk about what properties it
must possess.
But if you're willing to open the door to
things that don't or can't exist, then of
course the sky's the limit on what
properties they do or don't possess,
because they might.
It's like the non elephant animals.
Things might not exist for a huge variety
of reasons.
However, things that exist, either from
an external measure measurement or from
self measurement, they must be acting as
if they're self evidencing, reducing
surprise relative to a generative model
path of least action through an
information geometric space.
If it isn't doing that, you're not going
to observe it.
And that's where we get the particular
partition and the particular partition in
the particular physics.
Bayesian mechanics since Karl Friston's
2019 monograph, free Energy Principle for
a Particular Physics, that was like a big
inflection point in this line of research.
.
Whereas in the 2016 to 2018, there's a
lot of qualitative work and the
philosophical work applying to multiscale
and nested systems and self organization
amidst other empirical simulations
happening continually in all of this
reading works of different times, like
different pieces are kind of going to be
made clear or not.
What is the role of precision in nested
models?
Well, here and also by way of
demonstrating the transferability of
active inference generative models, these
three figures are discussed in live
stream 28 from the original paper.
Smith et al.
Computational phenomenology.
So this is a static perceptual Bayesian
model.
We have hidden state observations and we
hear as a modulator, literally a
neuromodulator on the A matrix Taylor two
densities recognition matrix generative
model.
You have the precision.
So precision is one over the temperature.
.
So whether you think of it as like higher
temperature is lower precision or lower
or vice versa, they're the same.
When your precision is low, your
temperature is high, a gets blurred out.
The high temperature limit is like A
becomes flattened, whereas in the low
temperature limit, A becomes sharpened.
And so this is a common method in
recognition modeling.
Okay?
Now they move into adding action in.
So here there's the policy.
Figure 4.3, figure 7.3, everything we've
looked at.
And then they move to this nested model.
Now, in the Sandbed Smith paper, it was
being mobilized in terms of basically
phenomenology meditative experiences,
direct sensory perception, visual
perception and isocades attention,
unreportable attention and then awareness
at a third level, observing that.
And so you can add an uncertainty, like a
precision on any variable.
You could have an uncertainty on your
prior d.
You could have uncertainty on all kinds
of things.
But sometimes uncertainties on specific
variables become associated with certain
cognitive phenomena.
In this case, they're using it to
describe introspective and explainable AI
systems, taking the exact same figures,
exact same formalisms, just moving them
into the AI setting.
So precision on A and here's that live
stream 28 and the slides and everything.
Precision on A is like sensory ambiguity,
precision on G.
So how precise are you on the free energy
that is associated with the affect in
this sophisticated affect?
Here's some discussion on Embodiment and
the Alexander technique.
So, suffice to say, precision and nested
modeling is basically like the general
precision concept, which is basically
used everywhere.
This is how we fit Bayesian models.
We have some hyper prior distribution on
a parameter.
And if that prior distribution is too
sharp, then it's a pathology of the prior.
.
It's too precise.
If it was too imprecise, you have an
underfit model.
So it's like that.
And especially in nested models,
precision plays a role in kind of gating.
.
Just in this case, it's a general
question.
So you could make it do anything,
basically.
But here the precision on A is like
gating, let's just say the first and the
third level.
So if there's no attention being paid to
sensory input, don't be surprised that
they don't come up to attention.
But if this gating can be like super
direct and forceful, then you'll have
propagation of informational causality on
this network up to the higher level.
Page 113 in the textbook.
All right, the decision this is about
planning as inference.
Which one of these questions was also
about the decision whether to model
alternative futures, counterfactual
futures conditioned upon policy selection.
.
How would the world change if I did this
or that?
Is largely tied up with the choice
between discrete and continuous models
because the idea of selecting between
alternative futures defined by sequences
of actions is more simply articulated
using discrete time models.
All right, so figure 4.3.
Figure 4.3 is like the rosetta stone.
It juxtaposes the discrete time
continuous discrete time generative model
and the continuous time generative model.
.
So I'll just copy this.
In the discrete time model, you have st
minus one s of t, s of t plus one.
So futures and pasts, if it's
sophisticated, active inference, are
being explicitly modeled.
So it's like what would happen at 07:00
if I did this?
That is explicitly addressable with a
discrete time model of the correct time
horizon.
So you have to explicitly say, I'm
talking about an hourly model and seven
depth.
And so then in branching time active
inference, just like a chess algorithm,
it's dealing with the branching structure
because if you have a lot of affordances
and you have a lot of time depth, you can
imagine this is a combinatorial explosion.
.
In contrast, though these two generative
models are shown here to emphasize their
structural similarity, the continuous
time generative model is actually not
explicitly modeling past, present, future
time steps.
Rather, it's modeling the generalized
coordinates of motion x hidden state x
prime rate of change, x double prime
second derivative.
So in that way, it's a lot more like a
Taylor series expansion.
So a Taylor series expansion, technically
even a Taylor series expansion of depth
one, it has an answer for every single
point in the number line, but that doesn'
't mean it's a good one.
And so continuous time models kind of
trivially have something to say about all
possible time steps just by analytic
continuation of the Taylor series
expansion in the generalized coordinates
of motion way.
However, you don't necessarily know how
accurate it is for any given point.
It also doesn't have explicit
counterfactuals.
So if you do some Taylor series expansion,
, it says yeah, at x equals three over y
is five.
But then if you say, well, what if it
were different?
The only way you could do that would be
change the parameters of the Taylor
series and recalculate it at that point.
So the model itself is not exactly doing
these.
Like what would happen if I did that?
So futures are explicit in discrete time
models and interpretable explicitly,
whereas in continuous time models, pasts
and futures are kind of trivially
predicted such that it doesn't really
make sense to talk about counterfactuals
in the same exact way.
And these models can be hybridized and
fused, which is in chapter eight.
Can we generate a code of template?
Looks like yes, but there's of course
more information.
But it's an important question.
How is temporal depth specific to
planning?
Does temporal depth in perception make
any sense?
What is temporal depth?
So temporal depth is how many timesteps
the model is considered in the discrete
time case.
Does temporal depth make sense in
perception?
Well, perception is always modeled as
instantaneous.
However, depending on the temporal scale
of a model, that perception may be
instantaneous over a certain temporal
thickness power.
Why is temporal depth specific to
planning?
So in planning as inference, policy
selection as inference, you're selecting
or sampling from policies based upon
their expected free energy.
In order to plan over a given time
horizon and actually evaluate the
playouts, you need to have a temporal
depth of that amount.
Thomas Parr in his bookstream so early
implementations were coming from the
generalized filtering approach.
Maybe it wasn't generalized at that point,
, but particle filtering approach.
And then quipped these models with action.
.
Then people started thinking about how to
get sequential dynamics.
Predator prey lock of voltera models
winnerless competition neural Darwinism
in these situations, there's an emergence
of sequential recurrent continuous
dynamics, like a limit cycle of more than
two.
Then people wanted to model explicit long
term planning.
And so from around 2014 or something,
there was a lot more development in the
discrete state space model, which enabled
the well understood, partially observed
Markov decision process and a lot of the
characterization of planning as inference
explore exploit.
Then later developments supported nested
models.
Here there's a discrete time on top and a
discrete time on the bottom.
But also it could be continuous time on
the bottom.
Oh yes.
Then continuous state models were
reintroduced as the lower levels of
higher level discrete time models.
And that is kind of like the folk
psychology Livestream 46 active inference
does not contradict folk psychology.
Discrete time decision making up top,
discrete time and discrete decisions and
then more in the sensory motor.
It's more like continuous time,
continuous action.
Okay, new question, figure 6.1.
All right, particular partition.
How is the mutual interaction between
active states and sensory states meant in
six one?
So the bi directional line here, can they
mutually change their states without
impacting neither internal nor external
states?
Yes, they could.
You could have nodes that these nodes are
in communication with each other.
In general, this image, it's more
important what it doesn't show.
So there's no backwards arrow from
external to active or from internal to
sensory.
You can't have your thumb on the scale
and the symmetry of whatever that is from
the outside.
And the only other constraint is no
telepathy.
No telekinesis.
The only way to receive information about
external states is through sensory states.
.
The only way to act on costly intervene
on external states is through active
states.
So no thumb on the scale and the mirror,
no telepathy.
No telekinesis.
That doesn't mean that for any given
model, these arrows are like all
important or all relative or relatively
of the same importance.
So if you want to design a computer
system where the sensory states comes in
one computer, and this is a second
computer and this is the third computer,
so like there's no direct edge between
sensory and active states, you can create
that causal architecture.
What is it supposed.
To model nothing.
Modeling of supposed things is done in
chapter six and beyond.
But in general, this is not trying to
model any specific situation despite the
brain in the world.
Could they circle mutually modifying
their states and then eventually arrive
at a state where they change the external
internal states?
Yeah, maybe they have a faster timescale
or something.
Or maybe they're in communication with
each other and then active states, like
sensory states ends up influencing
internal states via active influencing it.
.
And so yes, it could happen.
Would that mean that we can model with
this trick, any arbitrary behavior?
It's not necessarily a trick, it's just a
particular partition.
Would that allow us to model Turing
equivalents?
I'm not sure if there's an understanding
of what formally demonstrates Turing
equivalents then, but I believe it's
possible.
I think as a Turing architecture, as far
as I understand it, abstracted from the
von Neumann architecture is basically
just saying, like, you can do a Turing
tape.
So I don't see why not.
Why would we need that?
512k ought to be enough for anyone,
right?
I don't know why we need it.
We expect it.
But yeah, these graphs in general are
more like the space of the possible with
the important caveats that were mentioned
with the no thumb on the scale and the
mirror and the no telepathy and no
telkinesis.
But how relevant these edges are or what
systems have what behavior or what
cognitive phenomena are granted by what
dynamics on graphs.
There's just no general answer to those
things because if you do a graph for one
setting, it's going to be different.
What did you mean when you said that any
entree could be ordered with any side
dish like that in this recipe theme that
we're in models that include continuous
or discrete variables or both, what is
meant by variable states or
observations?
How can states be continuous, as those
here are probably familiar with?
States or observations could be like
discrete, like zero or one or any integer.
.
Or it could be a continuous number.
Computers discretize continuous functions
to approximate them.
But there's so many exciting directions
with unconventional computing, analog
computing, mem computing, et cetera, that
there's more to it.
But just simply it could be any type of
variable.
This new question, let's maybe look at
this one in closing, if the external
state is unknowable, how can we set up a
generative process so that's what's
generating the observations when our
experience is based solely on the process
of producing variational free energy
based on predictions and sensory inputs
across the markup blanket?
This person has just described the
challenge of life.
I don't think that there is a specific
answer to that.
I think this is literally a restatement
of the particular partition.
If this was just said, the challenge is
to given the unknowability, direct
unknowability of internal states.
The challenge and the opportunity is to
set up a generative model based solely on
the process of reducing free energy,
based on predictions and sensory inputs
across the blanket and adaptive action.
I'm not sure if they meant process or
model here because setting up a
generative process is something that the
human modeler does when they're designing
a simulation, but not like what the
animal has to do.
What I'm trying to get at here is we are
making an assumption about the generator
of sensory input when making the model.
Yes, but that model can never be accurate.
.
Well, it absolutely can be accurate.
It's never going to be a one to one map
is the territory, but of course it can be
accurate.
We don't need to understand have an
atomic simulation of the sun to have a
generative process of how many photons
are going to hit my window tomorrow at
07:00 a.m..
So there's a core invalidity in the
notion that we set up a generative
process model.
Not sure what ontology mixing is
happening, but almost by definition we're
introducing an error in the model by
setting up the parameters for the
generative process.
The generative model, we remove the
fundamental aspect of actin, which is the
dynamical system has only one thing it
can do and that's to reduce free energy.
So there's some good points and some
mixed things.
What it does is the action it takes in
the world variational.
Free energy is just a tractable
computational heuristic.
Yes, if you set up the generative process
to be a number continuous number between
one and ten and then the generative model
to do the exact same, to kind of have pre
structurally learnt the problem, then it'
's going to be a simple simulation.
Whereas you could have a more
sophisticated simulation that involves
structured learning as part of the agent'
's generative model.
Are we not introducing information to the
model that would not be available in the
real world if we actually defined the
generative process?
Yeah, you can give any model too much
information, essentially.
So if the model actually knows what is
really happening, then if you were doing
a video game and you had an agent with
supervisory access to the other players
inferences or even control their actions,
yeah, that's not going to work in a
tournament.
But here with a particular partition, we
can actually know the information
encapsulation.
And Majid Benny explores that in terms of
the partial information encapsulation.
So are we not introducing information to
the model that would not be available?
It's your restaurant, do whatever you got
to do with the recipe.
If you want a pedagogical example that
just makes some clean graphs and is very
straightforward and doesn't engage the
complexities of like sophisticated
cognitive structure learning, that model
is not going to complain.
If you want to do strange loop reflexive
structure modeling for ambiguous inputs
of unstructured multimodal data, et
cetera, then that is your challenge.
So for many people it's just one closing
comment.
In many people.
This is the first time they've been
exposed to statistical modeling, and
iterative modeling formally.
So that's why there are often questions
that are, like, less about active
inference, but sometimes crop up about
basically using statistical modeling
overall, which is a great thing because
these are challenging and areas with a
lot of implicit and tacit knowledge.
Thank you, fellows.
Looking forward to next discussions and
into heading into chapter seven next week.
.
Ali, maybe we'll do a maybe we'll do our
zero for chapter seven and eight, but not
in a hurry.
But we'll figure it out.
Andrew: Sure.
Thank you so much.
Daniel: Thank you.
Speaker C: Thank you.
Daniel: Bye.